okay this is a Diamond digger saga level
10 4 walkthrough tutorial this is a
tough level and it's because of where
the totems are set up there's a lot of a
lot of space underneath them on some of
the rooms and this is a thing that
repeats itself over time through all the
higher levels so that we make an extra
video commentary to show you how to
approach it the first room is pretty
easy most of the time and we got a great
set up this time so with two matches we
can drop this totem and get out of the
room that will give us more moves for
the more difficult rooms where we can
get stuck in our God we talk about all
the different ways to look at how to
approach these and if you haven't read
that i would i would recommend it so
this is the example of where it can be
really tough there's only a little bit
of space so you have to plan things out
to make sure that you drop things in a
way that you can and so that you don't
get stuck underneath here where you
can't make any matches because it's
really hard to clear things out from
above we got another fortunate kind of
setup here because we can drop though we
could do it either way actually we could
drop the yellow and get it download and
match the green and be able to remove
the pink so we'll go ahead and do that
and like I said sometimes this can be
jumbled up down here and it can be you
can just get stuck here and not be able
to finish the board no matter how many
moves you came in with so that's lucky
and another nice setup or we can drop it
straight down so you know planning is
important even whenever it looks simple
because one wrong match can get y'all
stock alright so as you can see here
it's going to be a little bit more
complicated we have one match ready to
go that'll get rid of one of these
groundhogs and then this one is
completely stuck at the moment and this
one we can drop without problem and we
can we can save this if we want because
we don't this there's nothing we're
going to do it's going to break up the
three on the right so what I'm going to
do is I'm gonna make this match because
that's just going to bring more yellows
into this match and see if we can't make
some progress over here because this is
the one's going to give us the most
trouble
and this is also going to get stuck now
as it is because the blue is going to
drop so we're going to have a blue green
blue green which is going to make things
complicated
when this yellow is not going anywhere
for right now Summerlee left and go
ahead and drop that one and then what I
need to do is try to get some green ones
to fall over here so I'm going to go
ahead and match above first to see if I
can do that so at least we have some
green on the board now make this one
that's going to set up another blue much
here but this yellow ones just stop so
I'm going to try to get rid of it first
and that will get us closer if we get
really lucky a green will fall on top of
here but this is a pretty good example
of how you need to plan things out ok so
the only of our booster and you have 15
moves 15 moves is probably enough to
recharge it and if you have last night
like say you have 10 or 11 I wouldn't
use it here i would just try to work my
way out but with 15 i think we can
recharge it so i'm going to go ahead and
do that because you absolutely need it
in the last room we can't finish the
last word without the booster so if you
have less than this even if you have
like 12 maybe or so i wouldn't i
wouldn't use the booster at all I'll
just save it but I'm going to go ahead
and do that I'm going to take this blue
one out because then I know I still have
the own and now i'm going to try to
bring another green one over here
on this much you can do either way you
could do yellow you can do blue first
and see if agree with balls or you can
just do the yellow I'm going to go ahead
and do the other because little charge
of the booster faster and then now you
can see we have a green where we want it
but our booster is not very charged so
we're going to hold off on this yellow
let me think i'm gonna go ahead and drop
that and then this is a pretty big match
right here so I'm not even going to mess
around I'm just going to go ahead and
into the third room because it's a tough
room anyways and you can make big
matches in there though it's not
impossible to be that so I'm not going
to burn a move like to make one of these
matches in here first I'm just going to
go ahead and get out of this room while
I can
and this is why you can't this is why
you need to charge the district because
there's no other blue ones and you can't
match these so these have to be removed
through the most or using the booster so
we're going to try to make some big
matches and charges as best you can this
one the green is a little it looks good
but if I match this yellow that's pretty
big and the greens are all going to come
together and give us another big match
so and we'll do that with that way same
with here we don't really need to drop
the bat down yet but if I match the
green person then the pink match them to
make next might be a little bit bigger
inside the booster a little bit faster
and that worked out pretty good
and so now you can look we have 9 News
left in the business three quarters of
the way charge so we don't have to worry
that much it's pretty it should it
should charge up at this point so I'm
just going to drop these tales and get
them ready
and we got five moves left the Boosters
charged so I'm going instead of taking
off the Blues right now I'm going to go
ahead and this match and the pink hats
will will finish that to the bottom so
we're going to do that first because I
get they'll get switched to ride off you
get rid of blues first and now we can
finish the logo so um obviously you're
not always going to get as good of a
beginning as I had there it's a tough
level but you will need some help to get
past it so just hang in there if it's
not working out take your time playing
things out and if you don't get a good
board what will happen then you're just
going to have to you know try again but
read our full guide make sure you leave
questions if you if you have some make
sure that you like the video if you
found it helpful and let us know if
there's other videos other levels that
you want to see one of these commentary
videos for and time permitting we'll
make one for you alright thanks